nothing racks up the ticket sales quite
like a based on a true story tagline but
as we all know Hollywood's version of
the truth doesn't always add up to the
actual facts sure crazy things happen in
real life all the time but screenwriters
still can't seem to resist juicing up
the story to make things better and
bigger evolution has programmed our
fabulous male brains to take anything
anybody else thinks is important and
make it bigger so what's real and what
isn't he has a look at some true story
movies that were anything but the
revenant historical facts checkers had a
field day with Alejandro G Inarritu
oscar-winning 2015 film the revenant
while Hugh glass played by Leonardo
DiCaprio was a real frontiersman who
survived some perilous obstacles yes
even a bear fight there was still plenty
of made-up moments the movie added for
dramatic flair according to historical
record glass did not have a son so the
movie's entire plot about him seeking
vengeance against the men who killed his
kid was completely fabricated and while
glass did go after John Fitzgerald
played by Tom Hardy for leaving him to
die in the woods glass never actually
got the opportunity to have the
face-to-face showdown like he did in the
movie instead he gave up his search
after finding out that Fitzgerald had
become an army member and was thus
protected by the federal government talk
about sounds like climactic man you're
more of a letdown and fruit stripe gum
hmm the walk let's just get this out of
the way yes Philippe Petit snail biting
tightrope walk between the two towers of
the World Trade Center was real and many
of the scenes and details depicted in
the walk were true that includes petits
lack of a harness or a safety net his
previous walk between the towers of
notre-dame in 1971 and the buildings
natural sway in the wind and petit
really was arrested for the stunts but
the charges were dropped as long as he
did a free performance of Central Park
but some of the details were well be
arranged to suits the pace and
personality of the film petit and his
team actually had to do 3 trips to New
York to prepare in
that of the one shown in the flick and
according to bustle in real life petit
hooked up with a groupie after being
released by police leading to his
breakup with Annie Alex who in the movie
was played by Charlotte's Lebon cheesy
on the lady who flew across the world
just to help you achieve your goals
that's a whole different kind of
tightrope walk The Texas Chainsaw
Massacre tobe Hooper's groundbreaking
1974 low-budget horror film The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre may have been
advertised as a true story but it's far
from it
while Leatherface is arguably on the
Mount Rushmore of famous horror movie
villains he really didn't get his
sadistic swag from a real-life chainsaw
wielding maniac like psychos Norman
Bates and countless other creepy bad
guys
Leatherface was loosely based on the
real-life killer ed gein gein who
confessed to killing two women was known
for exhuming corpses from graveyards and
making keepsakes and furniture out of
their remains while these actions
heavily influenced the creation of
Leatherface his family and the decor of
the soyuz household basta belts it when
it comes to the Chain Saw Massacre being
a true story Cinderella Man Ron Howard's
2005 biopic Cinderella man wasn't too
far off the mark when it came to the
central story of boxer James Jay produc
a heavyweight champ who came back from
bitter defeats to win the belt from Max
Bayer however the movie also turned
products in the ring nemesis into an
over-the-top cinematic villain nothing
like Baio was in real life
while it's true that Bayer accidentally
killed opponent Frankie Campbell in the
ring bay a son Max Baer Jr was
reportedly enraged by the scoundrel his
father was portrayed to be in the movie
he said the portrayal of my father and
Cinderella man couldn't have been more
wrong and inaccurate they turned a
good-hearted fun-loving friendly and
warm human being who hated boxing into
mr. t from Rocky 3 with no redeeming
characteristics no I don't hate but I
pity the fool and I will destroy any man
who tries to T what I got baya himself
was once quoted as saying nothing that
ever happened to me nothing that's can
happen
to me affected me like the death of
Frankie Campbell he ended up raising
money for Campbell's Widow and son and
claimed to have nightmares about the
man's death the Fourth Kind the 2009
sci-fi thriller the Fourth Kind was
marketed as a true story of the
mysterious disappearance of several
people from Nome Alaska in October 2000
everything in this movie is supported by
archive footage some of what you're
about to see is extremely disturbing the
mayor of the town tonie's Michaels
cautions that the supposed true story
that inspired the movie is quite
different than what was shown and this
has caused her towns officials some
immense headaches from truth hunters who
called in after the film's release
Michaels told CNN people need to realize
that this is a science fiction thriller
some of the calls I'm just ignoring
because the issue he had to deal with
him real life was very sensitive what
really happened was a string of traveler
disappearances in 2005 which the FBI
investigated and determined was caused
by a combination of alcohol consumption
and freezing temperatures in the area
the facts that the movie poised itself
as a combination of actual documentary
footage spliced together with Mia
dramatizations of the same was a
convincing seat filler in the vein of
The Blair Witch Project and the
paranormal activity but the movie was
ultimately labeled a hoax for its
blatant misrepresentations of the truth
not that anybody was really surprised
catch me if you can Steven Spielberg's
2002 caper movie catch me if you can
wouldn't have been the same without the
thrilling game of cat-and-mouse are
played out between Tom Hanks's FBI agent
Carl Hanratty and Leonardo DiCaprio's
version of the real-life Frank Abagnale
but if the movie had really echoed
reality Tom Hanks wouldn't have been a
part of it at all
according to USA Today Hanks his
character was actually a combination of
multiple agents who had followed
Abagnale through his many careers in con
artistry one of the first scams Abagnale
pulled off in the movie was a
fabrication built just for the big
screen namely when Abagnale a high
schooler himself convinces a class that
he's a substitute French teacher that
didn't happen
Abagnale also called shenanigans on the
scene in which DiCaprio's character
cools up his nemesis in the FBI out of
sheer desperation and loneliness on
Christmas Eve
he asked why would I do that I didn't
want the FBI to know where I was good
morning Vietnam the real life account of
Adrian Cronauer as time was a plucky
disc jockey during the Vietnam War it's
pretty intriguing
but when Robin Williams stepped in to
portray Qin OA in good morning Vietnam
things took a definite turn towards left
field
the real Cronauer admitted that the
American veteran census 2008 conference
that he wasn't quite as kooky in reality
as his on-screen persona well those of
you who have been in the military know
if I had done half the stuff that Robin
Williams did in that movie I'd still be
in Leavenworth this morning instead of
Washington among the major jumps from
reality was the fact that kanawa wasn't
actually kicked out of Vietnam as a
result of his on their antics and most
of the lines were ad-libbed by Williams
when our admits Williams as the disc
jockey I would have liked to be the
movie is much more interesting than the
experience as I had Robin Williams as
very funny I'm not still the most famous
line in the movie came directly from Qin
our so at least a title of the movies
accurate thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]